Niko, did you see the gif?
Niko: It sounds really complicated
Niko: Jimmy and Freddie go up there,
Niko: and Jimmy goes into the shack
Niko: and then he comes out and he's like
Niko: "Freddie, Freddie you need to see this."
Niko: There we go, *laughs*
Jake: Step in my office
Jake: But you think I'm scared of a little hairs getting ripped on my toes? Thats a lot of work
Jake: It's tough man
CM: Ready to change your life?
Jake: I'm Jake Watson. I'll be your host
Jake: I just gotta lean into this s-ubscribe?
Jake: How is he the nicest unity and not human
CM: When you're cooking you don't want the wind to blow out your fire.
Sam: It's never gonna work
Sam: There is merely one Jam
Sam: Merlin's pants
Sam: Caesar's Ghost
Sam: Fiddlesticks. Snickerdoodles. Mother Schmucker.
Wren: I think it'll happen and then it happens
Wren: The Edit needs to be done like now
Wren: Half our computers don't work
Wren: Can't remember the last time I pulled an all-nighter
Wren: This video is turning into a nightmare
Wren: Every hour that goes by I fail even more
Wren: Supposed to be the easiest shot
Wren: These sandwiches are the best, Jenna makes them
Sam: *Strange Noise*
Niko:  Now that's what we call art
CM: When you're cooking you don't want the wind to blow out your fire
Niko: Now I know this isn't the regular video that we put out in this channel
Niko: But when I came into work this morning Carmichael was so excited. He was like, "Niko!"
Niko: "Did you see the gif?" I- I didn't see the gif, and he showed me the gif
Niko: And it's what you just saw there. That incredible animation was done by a guy named Garrett Frickey. You can check out his YouTube channel
Niko: It's a goop2526 here. Garret made this incredible animation sent it over to us
Niko:You know what Garrett it is so good
Niko: Then we need to add some sound and we need to add some music and we need to put this up on the channel
Niko: ASAP and Garret was like "that would be cool." So Garret this is to you. Show Garret some love in the comments down below ASAP
Niko: If you wanna check out his channel go for it
Niko: Just has three videos on there one look like just dancing goats. Whatever go get some thumbs ups. Anyways, consider subscribing